- Hi, everybody.
I'm just gonna say hello everybody.
My name is Jeanne Garbarino
and I run up science program called
RockEDU Science Outreach.
And that is in New York City.
And one of the things that we like to do
as part of RockEDU is hanging
out with kids like you
and talk about science.
And I'm so super pumped to introduce you
to scientist Mollie from
another awesome program
based in New York City called the BioBus.
And the BioBus is special
because it talks about
microscopes with kids in
schools, just like you.
So I'm gonna mute myself
and I'm gonna hand
everything over to Mollie
because she's our special
scientist for the day.
And I would love for
you all to ask questions
and really pay attention
to what she has going on
because I think it's
gonna be very exciting.
All right, I'll talk to you guys later.
- [Molllie] Hi everyone.
So that is correct.
My name is Mollie
and I work onboard
something called the BioBus,
which is a science laboratory
that we've put inside of,
can you guess where we put it inside?
Yeah. I see a hand up.
Claire, go ahead.
- [Claire] A bus.
- [Mollie] Exactly.
We put it inside of a bus.
Can you imagine, so like,
think about your school bus,
if you take a school bus to school,
and take out all the seats
and instead if you put a whole science lab
full of tools like this
one right next to me
and things for us to collect samples with
and that's what we've done.
And some exciting news is that
I'm actually no longer in New York.
And in fact, I am trying to
bring us a brand new BioBus
in Massachusetts.
So this might be something
that in the future
we can even come and visit you with.
So I'm from Massachusetts
originally, and I'm here now.
So not too far away from all of you.
And so, what I wanna do today is
look at some samples that
I collected just outside
of my apartment.
And it doesn't look like
very much right now.
I'll show you what it looks like.
Anything you notice?
You can throw things in the chat
or if you want, you can raise your hand
just so that we don't
get too much feedback.
We can have people one at a
time call out what they see.
What do you notice?
- [Jeanne] Someone in the chat,
Claire says dirt and Ava asks.
- Bugs, I love it.
Those are kind of questions.
I wanna try and answer about it.
You're right.
There's some dirt and
there's even I have a larger,
there's something in a plastic cup.
Yeah. I like to recycle things.
So this is just from some takeout food,
and it's become a scientific tool for me.
Did you know that
scientists often use things
that they, just like the rest of us
like Tupperware things
they have around the house
as scientific tools?
So this is one.
I went outside today and I collected
I would call it a leaf litter.
I love that.
"Maybe there's worms in it," Claire says.
"Moon rocks."
I wish, that would be cool.
I mean, I don't know
what's in my leaf litter.
It would be difficult for me to identify
if it originally came from the moon.
We need a geologist.
- [Jeanne] Mollie, there's
a chat here that says
that somebody is named
McLean named a bug, Bart.
- [Mollie] Wow. Okay.
I like that.
Has anyone here ever had like,
maybe a thumbs up if you've
tried to keep a bug alive
inside your house before.
Some thumbs up for that.
And you can also give me a
thumbs down if you haven't.
But just so I can see, who here
has ever tried that before?
Some yes and nos.
Okay. Who here has ever
tried to keep a plant alive
inside your house before?
A few more thumbs up with that one.
I see some mes in the chat.
That's great.
So when I grew up,
I used to love learning
about living things
by doing exactly that.
I would keep them alive in my house
which my parents weren't
always super happy about,
or I'd go outside and look
at them really closely.
And that's a really great way
for all of you to be a scientist.
Just exactly with the things that you have
with your eyes, and your
ears, and your nose sometimes.
And really, I try not
to use my taste so much
when I'm observing in science.
There's some times that that's appropriate
but not if I'm looking at bugs.
Now, why am I saying all of these things?
Today, I have a special
tool for us to use together.
And it's the one, it's behind.
We've already told you what it is called.
Throw in the chat.
Tell me, what is this?
Do you remember what this tool,
the name of this scientific
tool right next to me is?
Excellent job.
You got Ava,
got some excellent microscope
answers coming in the chat.
This is a microscope.
And something very special
about it is, I have equipped it
with a camera on top, which is great
because how would you
all feel if I might look,
this isn't the most fun
tool on earth to use
and I'm just gonna use
it and you can watch me.
Does that sound like a good idea?
I'll just use it.
I'll look into it like this.
Then you can just all look
at the back of my head.
I don't think so.
So what we've done instead
is I've made it so that
I can give you all microscope vision.
You will be able to see everything
that the microscope sees
and we'll make discoveries together.
I don't know what we'll find.
'Cause like I said, I
just collected the sample
and it could have all
sorts of things in it
and we're gonna have to discover.
So I'm gonna practice microscope vision
before I put the sample on.
So what I need from all of you,
there's a little bit of
participation involved.
What I need from all of you
is you're gonna give me a countdown,
three, two, one, and then you point at me
and I'm gonna get the
microscope initialized
and ready to show onto the screening.
And when I do that,
right now, nothing on the microscope
and I'm gonna put a mystery object
and we're gonna look at that
with our microscope vision.
Okay?
I will give you one hint.
The mystery object is something
I imagine you all have
very nearby right now.
So let's do a countdown.
Ready?
Can you give me a three, two, one,
microscope vision.
Okay.
It kind of looks like we're
underwater or something.
What do you notice?
There's nothing really going on yet.
You can kind of adjust the image.
But like I said, I don't
have a sample on here.
You're looking at kind of the glass.
Now I'm gonna just move my
hand across the microscope
and let me know what you see.
That's my hand.
Can you see my fingernail?
So we're pretty zoomed in.
That's how zoomed in we are right now.
That's a familiar object.
Now, we are going to put
on our mystery test object.
So I'm gonna, just like before,
I'm gonna slide it across.
Well, okay, I'll stop right there.
Using your skills of
observation and your eyes mainly
in this case.
Meat, that's an interesting
observation maybe
because it's got that sort of texture.
Lots of little kind of on
some gritty worm, sponge,
I like that, cheeseburger.
'Cause it looks like it's
got that yellow cheese.
I like it.
Rock, I'll move around a little bit more.
Keep them coming.
Keep these guesses come in.
I'm gonna move around a little more.
Ellie got it.
Nice job.
A pencil.
This is a pencil.
I think it's even the
classic if I move over here.
Does anyone have a pencil
just like this near them?
This is like a Ticonderoga pencil.
Yeah, I see one.
Awesome.
So we are looking at a pencil
and I love we got some questions there.
How?
How do we do that?
So I took this and I put it right on
the part of the microscope
where the action happens.
This is called the stage.
This is also where I put my hand.
This image went up through
this kind of black thing.
We'll get into what's
inside there in a minute.
And then it went all the way up.
And in this case, it went up to a camera
and that camera, and you see this cord
goes all the way to my computer,
and it attaches to all of you.
A lot of the time when I use a microscope
I don't have the camera and I use these.
Then these allow me to look straight down
and see the same thing.
So what you just saw is
exactly what you would see
if you were here with me
and able to look through
these eyepieces is what we call them.
So an eyepiece if I take one
right here, I can show you,
whoa.
What happens when I hold this up?
That's kind of bizarre.
I just turned my head upside down.
I know, it's kind of cool.
So lenses can do all sorts
of interesting things
but basically they take an image
and they can manipulate it.
They can make it bigger or smaller
or sometimes they can flip it.
I'm wearing them on my face right now.
Does anyone else have
lenses on their face?
Yes, I see some glasses.
So a similar thing happens here.
It's a smaller lens, but
it's basically the same thing
as what's inside of my
microscope right now.
Are we ready for some living samples?
Does anyone have any
questions before I do this
about how my microscope
works or what we just saw?
GA.
- [GA] When you put something
on the microscope head,
how do you see it from the lenses?
- That's great.
That's a great question.
So like I said before, up here is a camera
just like a camera that
you take pictures with.
It's just like,
imagine if I'm pointing
that down through a hole
at the top of my microscope,
you can kind of see where this tube is.
And that points all the way
down through the big lens,
which is here.
So basically, my camera's
pointing right through
and then just like the camera
that I'm using on my computer
it just goes straight into Zoom.
So I have a cable and
it runs all the way in
and I can just select
it as one of the cameras
that you get to see my picture with.
I'm not sure who was first
but I see William and then
Kate have their hands up.
William, why don't you go ahead?
- [William] What's inside the microscope?
- That's a great one.
So if I take my microscope.
Let me see if I can do this.
I just took the body of the microscope off
and I'm even gonna flip it
so you can see those are
the two lenses that go down.
One comes from each eye
and they go down
and then that's basically it.
There's a couple of
lenses that are stacked
on top of each other inside of here.
And then the path of that
image will either go to my eyes
or up to the camera here.
And down here, you can
kind of guess what this is.
I'll put the body of my
microscope aside for a second,
hold this up.
This is pretty straightforward.
What do you see going on here?
I can actually turn it off and on.
This is the main thing that
this part of microscope does.
This is just the light.
So I can either have a
light come from the bottom
or I can have a light
that comes from the top
depending on what sample I'm looking at.
If I can shine light through it,
then I'll use the one underneath.
And if I can't, then
I'll use the one on top.
Does that answer your question, William?
Awesome.
Okay. Who was next in our stack?
I think it was was Kate before
but then a bunch of other
people also raised their hands.
So the order that I have
you in is I have McLean,
then Paige, then Kate, then Sian.
So let's try that out.
McLean or Theodore maybe.
I don't know which one.
What should I call you?
- [McLean] I did my real name.
My first name, my middle
name and my last name.
- Amazing, okay, great.
What's your question?
- [McLean] The internet
connection is unstable.
- That's okay, I can hear you, go ahead.
- [McLean] If you move the
BioBus to Massachusets,
is it like a big bus or it's one?
Did I ask the question properly?
- No, that's an excellent question.
A lot of people are curious about this.
We have two of them.
They are both quite large.
They are 40 feet long
so it probably could not
fit inside of the classroom.
And if we have one in Massachusetts,
I don't know what shape it will take yet.
We'll decide based on what
kind of laboratory we need.
So maybe you can help me
decide what kind of lab
we should bring to Massachusetts.
Okay.
I'm gonna go back to do,
we had three people who
had their hands raised.
We'll do three more questions
and then we're gonna get into our sample.
So I wanna make sure we have enough time.
So Paige, go ahead.
- [Paige] Can you see germs
through the microscope?
- Great question.
Yes. We can see germs through microscopes.
This is a great tool for seeing
things that are that small.
This microscope is not quite
powerful enough to see a germ,
however, I have another one right here.
They all look the same.
This microscope has a
bunch of different lenses
that I can zoom in
and I look at things that are even smaller
with this kind of microscope.
There are microscopes that
can allow us to see things
as small as atoms, as small as atoms,
So that is like the smallest
possible piece of something.
But they don't all work the same way.
So I have a microscope that's
meant for looking at things
that are alive and moving
around like insects today.
That's a great question.
Our two final questions we
have Kate and then Sian.
- [Kate] Is the microscope hard to use?
- It's not hard to use.
All that I need to do when I use it
is really worked with
these two knobs here.
One of them I'll show you
when we're using it again,
allows me to zoom in and get close.
And the other one allows me to focus
which is to make it clear
if it's kind of blurry
and that's all I need to do.
So this microscope is
very straightforward.
Other microscopes can take
years to learn how to use.
So it's like I said before,
there's a lot of different kinds,
but the one that we generally
use onboard the BioBus,
the two kinds are both things
that you can learn to do yourselves.
Okay. Our last question
before we get to our sample
and I'm sorry that I
didn't get to everybody.
I know you all have a lot
of interesting thoughts
and questions.
Go ahead, Sian.
- [Sian] I saw some videos of people
looking like they use a microscope
to look for germs.
And on the video, they said,
if you look in a human's
body with a microscope,
you'll see some germs.
- Yeah. That's actually
extremely important
and interesting place that biologists,
scientists that study living
things are working now.
In your body, you have trillions of cells
but there are also probably
trillions of bacteria cells.
So you have your own body, your own skin,
your own blood cells.
You also, inside your body,
have tiny little bacteria
and all sorts of other living things
that make their home inside your stomach,
inside your throat, in
your nose, your ears,
and those all help to protect your body
to help you digest your food,
to help you keep other
things from getting inside.
Of course, sometimes we can
have things inside our body
that aren't good for us
as well, that are alive,
but we rely on trillions of those things.
We are an ecosystem.
I'm gonna put that word in the chat.
This one's really important for me.
This is the kind of thing
that I study as a scientist.
I don't study the human
body, but I study ecosystems.
Is that word familiar?
Can you throw a thumbs up or thumbs down
if you've heard that word
before, an ecosystem?
Excellent. Okay.
So with that, I think that's
actually a great place
for us to shift gears.
We're going to look into this ecosystem
and I'll write the name of
this one in the chat as well.
I call it the environment
that I got this from,
I'll call this leaf litter,
which is a kind of funny name.
Let's think about what that can be,
leaf litter just means that on the ground,
maybe you've noticed this before.
Especially sometimes in the
spring, after we had the fall
when all the leaves came down,
over the winter and into the spring,
things get stepped on
and it gets broken up
into teeny tiny little
pieces until we have
just these little fragments
of leaves left behind.
And then that ends up
being a really great home
for all sorts of living things.
So what I want to do is to
take just a little piece
of my leaf litter,
not a piece of it, I guess
I'm just gonna pour some of it
into something called a Petri dish.
Is this familiar?
Has anyone ever seen something like this?
It's just a little plastic dish.
And this allows me to view
this under the microscope
more easily.
I could just put this on but
I think this will make
it easier for us to see.
So I'm gonna pour just a little bit.
And I see I've got some dirt,
there's some pine needles in there.
All sorts of things going on.
Hopefully, if we're lucky
we'll also find some living things.
Now, gonna put it on a microscope
and I'm gonna rely on you.
You know what to do.
I'm gonna need a countdown
in order for us to see this.
So can I please get a three, two, one?
Okay.
Interesting.
We already found something alive.
What's going on?
So you can see if it's fuzzy,
remember I'm using that focus.
The thing that allows it to be clear.
Wow.
What do you think?
Is this a familiar?
Caterpillar or maybe a worm.
Love those guesses.
I have a little more
information than you all
because I can see it
also with my eyes, but
yeah, it seems like we've
got a few more votes
for worm than caterpillar
and I would tend to agree.
You see, it's kind of slimy.
Look at that.
It's moving around a lot too.
It's making me work to look at it.
So I'm kind of following it around
just by moving that Petri dish.
And notice exactly it's covered in dirt.
So all over its body,
it's got little tiny
pieces of dirt stuck to it.
There's a spot where it's staying still.
So I'm gonna zoom in and
then I have to refocus.
I see some little, it
looks almost like plastic
or something stuck to it too.
Little bit of actual litter.
That was so cool.
So we have at least one
living thing in here.
Let's poke around a little more.
You'll notice throughout the whole time
we're using the microscope,
I'll be kind of zooming,
and focusing, and moving it around.
And that's sort of part of my exploring.
Everybody has a piece of
paper and a pencil or a pen
or something to write with.
Let's find somewhere that
we can stop for a second
and we can even draw what we see.
So maybe right about here,
this is kind of a cool spot.
This is like the backdrop
of our little ecosystem.
So why don't you all
draw a picture of this?
This is our leaf litter.
This is a nice one because
I think I have a little bit
of an Oak leaf in the back
and then I've got this pine needle upfront
and I noticed there's
something interesting going on
with this pine needle.
I don't really know why.
The worm is moving things around.
I don't really know why,
but it's got these little
black circles on it.
It itself is not moving, that's the worm.
I think it got stuck to the pine needle.
That would be a crazy plot twist
if the pine needles
started crawling around.
So I'll give you all a few more
seconds to draw what you see
and then, I see something
else that I found today.
Pull that one.
I love these drawings.
Thank you for showing me.
That's great.
Amazing.
Now, let's do one more drawing.
I'm gonna switch samples.
I took one thing out.
I would call that I isolated a specimen,
something that looked interesting to me
and I took it away from the leaf litter
so it wouldn't be so hard to see.
And now I'm gonna move it
into the middle of the microscope.
I had hundreds of these around
my apartment this morning.
So if you look for them yourselves,
I would bet you could find them.
They were just waking up, I
think, from a long, cold winter.
Yeah. So that's a great guest.
Centipede.
It is definitely got a
lot of legs going on.
Whoa.
Now it's on the move.
Now it's starting to move around.
In these situations,
I'm gonna try to keep it
so that we can see where it's going.
It's kind of like playing a video game.
I have to guess what
direction is gonna move in.
I found the edge of the dish.
It's got these teeny tiny little antennas
that help it sense the world around it.
So, a centipede is a great guest.
I believe that this is a
teeny species of a millipede.
It's a little bit difficult
to tell the difference
between them, but usually millipedes legs
stick kind of straight down from his body.
I love these drawings again.
Excellent.
And a centipedes legs kind
of stick out to the sides.
That's one way I can tell
the difference between them.
But they both like to kind of roll up
into little circles to protect themselves.
Okay. I'm gonna come back.
Excellent.
There's an entire world inside
of this tiny little jar.
If we kept looking,
I bet we'd continue to see
really teeny, tiny things.
Little insects of all sorts.
I have a question for you though.
And it kind of relates.
I got from McLean.
"Why do we have to look at bugs?"
"What are some other living things
that you would be curious to
see underneath a microscope?"
This is really useful for me
because sometimes I have things
in my house that I can show.
But what would you be most interested in?
Now that you've gotten
to use a microscope,
what would you like to see?
What would you investigate closer?
I'll let you think about it for a second.
What do I mean?
If you had this in your
classroom with you right now
what would you be most
excited to see under it?
What kind of living thing?
Let's limit it to living things
'cause there's so many
things in the world.
Let's try a living thing.
What would you be curious to see up close?
So Williams says a spider.
Liam, I see your hand up.
Go ahead.
- [Liam] I think I'd
like to see a Chrysalis.
- I love that idea.
Yeah. So could we look at something
that was actually going through
some sort of a metamorphosis,
something like that?
I heard you all.
Might've been learning about a life cycle
or life cycles this year.
Is that right?
I do have a sample.
I don't have a Chrysalis,
but I do have a few samples
of another animal that are
going through a life cycle.
Should we have that be
our last sample for today
that we look at?
You guys can try and you can guess,
you can try to guess
what it's gonna become.
Sian, go ahead.
- [Sian] I forgot what I was gonna say.
- That's okay.
And I did actually mean,
I was curious what other animals
people wanted to look at.
And I see some have come up in the chat.
Someone said maybe a bear or a wolf.
That would be cool to
look under a microscope
but you have to choose a part of its body.
Maybe just it's fur, or you
could put its teeth, a tooth
under the microscope and
see what that looks like.
Butterflies would be really beautiful.
To look at my lifecycle sample,
I've got four different stages of its life
and they're preserved.
So what that means is it's
in a special kind of plastic.
So it's kind of like frozen in time.
And we're gonna start off with this one.
They're really tiny, little specs.
So I'll put on our microscope
vision one last time.
So let's do a
three, two, one.
Beautiful.
And so, this is the beginning
of our mystery animal's life.
Starts out like this.
A lot of animals start out
as something like this.
What does this look like to you all?
Well, those are guesses
about what it could be
but exactly, Claire got it.
These are its eggs.
We don't know what kind
of eggs they are yet
but these are certainly
the eggs of this animal.
They're kind of just small and round.
If I turn them over to the other side
maybe they'll look different on this side.
No, just kind of round,
not extremely interesting.
So I'll take this one off
and we'll go to the
second stage of its life.
Here we go.
Put this one under a microscope.
It's a little bigger now.
And it's got these.
Wow, it's got these pretty giant eyes.
We've got a guess for this one.
Now, maybe a beetle or a cockroach.
We've moved away from our
idea that this is a frog.
It's got longer, pointier legs.
Little hooks on them.
Pretty wild shape.
If I look in at the very front of it,
I can see it's even got
these almost like pinchers.
That's pretty wild.
Then the plot thickens, it
gets a little bit bigger.
Wow.
Now, I'm gonna zoom out
so we can try to see it a little better
but it got a little bigger, but
has all the same body parts.
So this is kind of like how we grow.
This body didn't really
change shape it just,
everything got a bit bigger.
So now the whole screen right
now is just this eyeball.
Let me zoom in on that a little bit.
A termite.
That's like a guess.
Now this is where it gets pretty bizarre.
So this animal has a life cycle where,
we've been observing and it
looks like it's got six legs.
It's got these kinds of pointy
structures all around it
but now it's gonna change.
So this is it as an adult.
It still has its legs and its eyes.
So I recognize the center of his body,
but out from the sides,
nice work, everybody,
you got it.
Dragonfly.
So it is very similar to an ant
because a lot of ants kind
of grow wings like this
as they get bigger.
But you'll notice the wings
of this are just gigantic.
They go off into all,
they get wings that are
a couple inches long.
Sometimes you get dragonflies
that are the size of your head.
Really big, really, really big.
This one is dead.
But it's a kind of species
we might find around here
if we wanted to.
I'll show you what they look like
without the microscope now.
So we started off here,
and then we went through these
different stages of its life.
And then this was the full-size dragonfly.
I think is kind of beautiful.
And I'll keep in mind
some of the other samples
you all suggested.
I too would be very interested
to see what the hair
or the teeth of some larger
predators might look like.
So I'll have to keep an eye out for them.
And sometimes when we
travel to new places,
you can find samples or
things that you wanna explore
and discover.
Like I said at the very beginning,
you can already do this with
the tools that you have,
your eyes, and your ears, and your nose,
making observations about living things.
And hopefully pretty soon,
we'll be able to bring a
laboratory like the BioBus
so you can use all this
equipment with your own hands
and get to try it out for yourself.
Does anyone have any last question
before we wrap up for today?
I love the emoji cat,
not even the symbols.
I'm surprised my cat often
likes to make little appearances
while I'm teaching.
I think he's taking a nap.
- [Jeanne] I think Ava,
you are saying in the chat
that you have a question.
Feel free to unmute yourself
and ask your question please.
- Your hand was up.
I didn't see it.
- [Ava] How often do you use microscopes?
- That's a great question.
I use them pretty much every day.
Different scientists use them
all different amounts of.
I used to work in a different
lab and it was near the sea.
I studied things that live in the ocean
and I would spend like an entire month
where I'd just be out collecting samples.
So wouldn't use a microscope at all.
And then I'd spend three
months just in the lab
looking at them under the microscope.
And then I wouldn't go back
to the microscope again
for awhile.
I'd be writing what I found.
So there's kind of phases of science
and some of them include the microscope
and some of them do not.
So McLean, I also saw Paige you had
your real hand raised.
So I wanna make sure I
hear from some voices
I haven't heard from yet.
So maybe let's let Paige go
ahead and ask a question.
And then I see Ellie,
you've got your hand up too.
- [Paige] Can you take
pictures on microscopes?
- Yeah. So this same camera.
That's a great question.
It can take pictures.
And that is a really important way
that scientists communicate
with one another now.
They take pictures and even videos
of what they see under the microscope
and then they share that
with other scientists
so that they are able to see
the discoveries that other people made.
And sometimes you can
make art with it too.
So that's one of my favorite
places where we can cross over
between science and art.
Ellie, I saw your hand was up.
And then Claire,
and then I think we have time
for one very last question.
- [Ellie] Have you ever seen
a bigger animal up close?
- Yeah, definitely.
We used to work in a
laboratory with BioBus
that had a big corn snake.
So that was when we used to
put it under the microscope
a lot and a turtle.
So this microscope, we can
look at pretty large animals
and I have another one that's handheld.
So we can even look at
our hair, and our clothes,
and our eyes.
We're a pretty big animal
I would say, right?
Okay.
Claire and then McLean
and then we're gonna have to wrap up.
- [Claire] Do microscopes have lights
so you can see it when
there's light on it?
- Exactly. Yep.
So remember that bottom
part of the microscope,
it has two different lights
and that's the only thing that
those lights are there for,
is so that the light can
travel through our lenses.
Without a light then it would be so dark
that you couldn't see anything.
But different microscopes,
they can use lasers or fluorescent light
or even electrons like
electricity to make an image.
They don't need to have light.
Okay. I think McLean, and
then we're gonna wrap up.
Go ahead.
You might be frozen for me.
Okay. If you want, you can
add questions in the chat.
And I see there's another one here.
"How do microscopes make things look big?"
So inside of it, the thing that
is really doing all the work
is extremely simple.
It's just a lens that's made out of glass.
And I have one here,
so you can see it's just a
piece of glass and it's curved.
If I hold it in front of my face.
So this is kind of like a
microscope and that's all it is.
It's a little piece of curved glass
and I can make things look really big.
That's pretty cool, right?
Lenses can be made out of
lots of different things
but most of the ones that
we use in microscopes
are made out of glass.
Well, this was wonderful.
So the question that I didn't get was,
have I ever gone on a
Safari to look at animals?
I haven't been on a Safari
but I have been on field.
I've done fieldwork around the world.
So the coolest place that
I got to work for my work
was in Ireland.
I worked in the world's largest tide pool.
It was like the size of a lake.
And it was full of all sorts
of interesting sea creatures.
So that was my version
of going on to a Safari
because I study things
that live in the sea.
- [Jeanne] That sounds amazing.
- Yeah. It's pretty great.
If you have any more questions,
you can always tell your teacher
and she can send them to me.
And hopefully, we'll get
to meet in-person someday.
- Thanks so much, Mollie.
We're so excited to have
the BioBus with us today
and we're so excited to have
all of you with us today.
Thank you for bringing
such wonderful questions.
Having Lab Backstage allows
us to get science anywhere
it needs to be.
So thanks to the internet
and thanks to Zoom for that,
I guess.
Anyway, friends, let's
give scientist Mollie
a big round of applause.
This is how I like to do it.
All right everybody,
have a great day
and happy sciencing.
- Thank you so much.
Fabulous.
- Thank you.
All right, take care